it's just crazy that we are now sat in a
fuel cell car that you can buy and you
can go fill it up with green hydrogen
and the only thing that comes out of the
backs water
I think hydrogen has great potential as
a fuel throttle bills in the very near
future for the past decades everyone's
been saying it's just around the corner
they're nearly there
I believe that today's children will one
day take your driver's test in a
hydrogen powered pollution-free car
genuinely believe that this technology
is gonna be beneficial for a little and
because we are and we aren't this rock
for a very small amount at a time I want
to make a difference
loving the main way that I can do that
is try to get the electrification of the
transport industry complete I'm an
energy reporter for the journal and I've
been hearing a lot about the promise of
hydrogen as the energy source for the
future as the global population and
economy expand the world's demand for
energy is expected to grow dramatically
in the next thirty years so some are
asking could hydrogen the most abundant
element in the universe help produce the
use of fossil fuels and boost the
adoption of renewable energy some of the
world's biggest companies believe in
hydrogen's potential and have invested
heavily they're betting they can build a
2.5 trillion dollar market around it but
there's also skepticism around it all
people embrace the hydrogen revolution
or is it over height this isn't the
first time scientists have been
captivated by hydrogen's potential as a
clean fuel source in 1874 science
fiction writer jewe Verne dreamed up a
world where we could create fuel from
water in the 1930s we saw the promise
and apparel of the Hindenburg the
hydrogen filled blimp that flew across
the Atlantic and exploded killing many
on board in the late 60s hydrogen fuel
cells helped power NASA's Apollo
missions to the moon while liquid
hydrogen was used as a rocket fuel in
other space ventures and after the oil
shocks of the 70s some wondered if
hydrogen could replace oil since then
technology has made great strides so I
wanted to understand
how exactly do we go from water to fuel
dr. Whitley took me to his lab to show
me how the whole process starts step 1
create or capture the hydrogen the
interesting thing about hydrogen is it's
the most abundant element in the
universe
which is great but it's not naturally a
clearing enough so it's always as you
say is tied up in other chemicals so how
do we get it how do we do it here the
process in electrolysis using the system
that we're developing here you put water
in apply some electricity to the system
and you get hydrogen coming out and
oxygen we discard the oxygen in the
atmosphere and then we store the ID once
that hydrogen is created it can be used
in three main ways to store energy
generate heat or in the case of hydrogen
powered cars electricity look at this
diagram created by Toyota hydrogen gas
is stored in this tank it flows through
a stack of fuel cells like this one
where it meets oxygen and creates
electricity that powers the car hydrogen
fuel cell cars are available in more
than 20 countries with brands like
Toyota and Hyundai selling models for
between 50 and 60 thousand dollars
before government incentives so this is
a representative example of what is in a
car now so co2 system Honda systems any
automotive manufacturer system uses
around 200 square centimeter membranes
so where is the R&D that we do is on
quite small ones because we don't want
to waste materials the real-world
application stuff is a lot bigger over
the last five to ten years fuel cells
have gotten smaller more efficient and
cheaper to make partly due to a
reduction in the use of costly metals
such as platinum now they pack a big
punch hydrogen fuel cells could be
especially useful for heavy trucks that
need to travel long distances and
require more energy than batteries are
currently able to provide they're
already being used to power everything
from cars drones and trains
some entrepreneurs think there's money
to be made my name is Adam bond I'm the
chief executive at AFC energy we're a UK
listed company over the last 13 or so
years and our business is really in the
development of hydrogen fuel cells so
through here we have the fuel cell
system and it's at its core are our two
fuel cell stacks which are both hidden
behind those blue end plates his idea is
that hydrogen can be used to charge
electric vehicles the number of hydrogen
powered passenger cars on the road
doesn't even come close to battery
electric vehicles and plug-in hybrids
and all those batteries need to be
charged what we've done is both
basically said well if you're not gonna
have a hydrogen car you you're probably
gonna have an electric car and so that
needs to be charged from from a
decarbonized source as well and that's
where we're our fuel cell comes into
play how much would I pay for something
like that something like that you're
probably looking at somewhere around
$100,000 when we went to AFC Adams said
they were in talks with potential buyers
like car park owners and shopping
centers but hadn't made any sales yet so
how are they able to do their work well
AFC has received government funding in
the past and in the 2019 financial year
they raised roughly seven million
dollars in equity and bonds UCL
currently relies on a mix of government
funding and private investment and
interest from businesses around the
world is on the rise more than 80
companies so far have joined an
initiative called the hydrogen Council
which aims to make hydrogen a key part
of the energy transition in 2017 its
members invested about 1.5 billion
dollars in hydrogen and fuel cells and
the group says it expects the number to
rise in coming years but here's the
thing for many of those companies
hydrogen is still just gonna be a sliver
of their business more importantly
there's some pretty big obstacles to
taking hydrogen main stream producing
the gas is still expensive because it's
not manufactured at scale and while
hydrogen fuel-cell technology works in
labs cars and refueling stations being
deployed primarily in Japan and Asia the
infrastructure isn't there in the rest
of the world yet
here in London the nearest hydrogen
refueling station is about 45 minutes
away this is what they were saying about
the freezin
so as you can see there's a lot of frost
on the outside of the nozzle and that's
because the gas is chilled so much
inside their machine that it can
temporarily freeze to the car but it
just comes off at the end but the price
is expected to go down hydrogen fuel is
comparable to the cost per mile for
gasoline in the UK but more expensive
than charging an electric vehicle and
history shows that major energy
transitions like this take a long time
it took more than a hundred years for
countries like the US Germany or China
to move away from burning wood and
primarily rely on coal and other fossil
fuels according to some experts not to
mention that most of the hydrogen that
we produced today is not produced
through a clean process hydrogen is used
in many industrial processes like the
production of steel special metals and
fertilizers in those cases hydrogen is
typically made using fossil fuels but
scientists say that hydrogen can be
created without releasing carbon dioxide
into the atmosphere by using renewable
energy through the electrolysis process
despite all the obstacles the
International Energy Agency says
hydrogen projects span a growing number
of industries more countries are
involved and it's seen as something that
can accelerate the adoption of renewable
energy and some scientists think
hydrogen might be about to change the
way we power the world this running joke
within the fuel cell community that
we're always a couple of years away from
mass commercialization and I heard that
when I started my PhD and now a few
years later we're still saying that but
I think now the state of the technology
right now and the way the industry is I
think we are now definitely on the verge
of the masculinization of this
you